elle revient à paris ce week end la nuit
blanche placée sous le signe de l'art
contemporain aux quatre coins de la
capitale est aussi en banlieue c'est
parti pour une nuit blanche et nuit
artistique de musique et lumière mais
pour sa première édition en 2002 les
festivités c'était fini tragiquement
tout d'abord à l'origine de la nuit
blanche deux hommes d'un côté l'ancien
maire de paris bertrand delanoë de
l'autre jean blaise directeur artistique
sa mission organiser des concerts des
projections des spectacles répartis sur
une trentaine de lieux insolites nuit
blanche c'est un parcours artistique
nocturne dans paris on va d'un lieu à un
autre comme dans un jeu de l'oie et
d'une surprise à une autre surprise
l'événement est gratuit les noctambules
ont le choix ils peuvent raconter une
histoire à l'artiste sophie calle en
haut de la tour eiffel vie en bulles et
dans les anciennes pompes funèbres de
paris ou encore jouer à des jeux vidéo
sur la façade de la bibliothèque
nationale de france dans la foule
bertrand delanoë lui aussi en profitent
au milieu de la nuit il flâne à la
piscine pontoise
[Musique]
la piscine
j'ai eu la tentation était
vers 2 heures du matin bertrand delanoë
retourne à l'hôtel de ville l'ambiance
est calme détendu le maire de paris
n'imagine pas ce qui va se passer et
trente minutes plus tard à 2h30 la
nouvelle tombe un inconnu s'est jeté sur
bertrand delanoë et lui a donné un coup
de couteau dans le ventre la blessure
est sans gravité et le maire de paris
est resté conscient le maire de paris
est agressée sans aucune raison par un
déséquilibré sur place bertrand delanoë
soigner puis transporté à l'hôpital de
la pitié salpêtrière
sa directrice de communication était à
ses côtés au moment de l'agression vous
savez vous marchez vous parlez j'ai vu
le maire tomber et je crois qu'il a
compris qu'il avait reçu un coup de
couteau parce que tout de suite il m'a
dit j'ai mal j'ai reçu un coup de
couteau pendant sa convalescence
bertrand delanoë sera remplacée pendant
plusieurs semaines par sa première
adjointe anne hidalgo selon ses
déclarations à la police son agresseur a
dit détester les politiques et les
homosexuels jugé pénalement
irresponsable en 2004 il a bénéficié
d'un non lieu et aille teigne en hôpital
psychiatrique
[Musique]